Lange bevor die Europäische Union der sichere Verbund von 28 Staaten war,
blickte vor 50 Jahren der ganze Kontinent auf die Tschechoslowakei.
Der burgenländische Landtagsabgeordnete Josef Bosch, welcher sich im Spätsommer 1968
in Pressburg aufgehalten hatte, kam bei Berg zu Fuß
über die österreichische Grenze und hat Folgendes zu berichten.
Um 11 Uhr Nachts wollten wir die Brücke über die Donau passieren und wir konnten das nicht,
denn der erste Panzer kam uns entgegen.
Diese Fahrzeugkolonne war zirka 4 Stunden lang, ich schätze,
dass es 300 Panzer waren die in Pressburg eingefahren sind.
Für uns war es vor allen Dingen interessant wie sich die Bevölkerung verhalten hat.
Um 12 Uhr Nachts waren schon die Leute auf der Straße, der Lärm der Panzer hat sie natürlich aus den Betten geholt.
Um halb 4 in der Früh war schon der erste
größere Wirbel.
Jugendliche haben bereits versucht die Panzer aufzuhalten.
Frauen sind ganz vorne gestanden und wollten mit Händen die rollenden Panzer stoppen.
Andere Jugendliche wieder rollten Benzinfässer gegen stehende Panzer.
Also es war bestimmt eine dramatische Nacht in Pressburg,
es sind auch zu dem Zeitpunkt Schüsse gefallen und sonst hat sich das wieder bis zur Früh etwas beruhigt.
Im Frühjahr 1968 kam es in der Tschechoslowakei zu einer politischen Reformbewegung.
Das herrschende politische kommunistische System sollte durch Reformen abgeändert werden
und mit einem menschlichem Anglitz versehen werden.
Der Parteichef der Tschechoslowakei Alexander Dubček leitete diese Reformbewegungen ein
und wollte einen Kommunismus mit menschlichem Anglitz schaffen.
Das was diese Reformbewegungen alles umfassen ist dann in weiterer Folge
als der sogenannte Prager Frühling bekannt geworden.
Über diese Entwicklungen der Tschechoslowakei zeigte sich vor allem die Sowjetunion extrem beunruhigt,
befürchtete sie doch, dass es zu einem übergreifen auf andere Staaten dieses kommunistischen Systems kommen könnte.
Man versuchte über politischen Druck Alexander Dubček zur zurücknahme dieser Reformen zu bewegen,
jedoch erfolgten diese nur sehr zögerlich, sodass man sich letztendlich zu einer militärischen Intervention entschied.
Nach der prinzipiellen Genehmigung der militärischen Intervention
begannen sich in der Nacht vom 20. auf den 21. August die Truppen des Warschauer Pakts in Bewegung zu setzten.
Die politischen Vorgänge in der Tschechoslowakei wurden natürlich auch in Wien
mit großer Besorgnis wahrgenommen.
Insbesondere das Militär rechnete, dass es
zu einer möglichen militärischen Intervention
in der Tschechoslowakei kommen könnte und plante unter dem Namen Urgestein
entsprechende militärische Grenzschutzmaßnahmen.
In den Morgenstunden des 21. August 1968
wurde das österreichische Bundesheer alarmiert und die Planungen für Urgestein ausgelöst.
Aufgrund politischer Vorgaben war es dem Bundesheer jedoch nicht gestattet
unmittelbar an die Staatsgrenze heranzugehen sondern in einer Distanz von 30 km zu verbleiben.
Letztendlich entschied man sich lediglich
die Garnisonen nördlich der Donau zu verstärken.
Im Gegensatz zum Krisenjahr 1956 bedeutete der Einsatz des Bundesheeres im Jahre 1968
einen großen Imageverlust für das österreichische Bundesheer.
Vor allem die Bevölkerung an der Staatsgrenze fühlte sich von den Streitkräften Österreichs im Stich gelassen
und auch der extra dafür aufgestelle Grenzschutz war nicht einberufen worden.
Die Weisung Urgestein sollte folgendes bewirken.
Alle mit dem Bundesminister für Landesverteidigung verfügten Maßnahmen sind unverzüglich durchzuführen.
Abmarsch der bereitgestellen Verbände sofort nach erreichen der Marschbereitschaft,
auf Weisung Gruppenkommando 1 und 3.
Es kommt darauf an rasch eine Grenzüberwachung sicherzustellen
um ein Übertreten von Flüchtlingen zu kontrollieren und diese in Sammellager aufzunehmen.
Kommando der Luftstreitkräfte führt mit Saab Einsatzflotte Aufklärungsflüge über eigenem Staatsgebiet durch.
Die Piloten sind streng anzuweisen Grenzverletzungen zu vermeiden.
Tatsächlich wurde Urgestein nach dem politischen Willen des Verteidigungsministers
Dr. Georg Prader und der Bundesregierung nicht umgesetzt,
sondern am 21. August 1968 lediglich die Verstärkung der nördlichen Garnisonen angeordnet.
Die Besetzung der Tschechoslowakei dauert nun schon mehrere Tage.
Wie erlebt die Zivilbevölkerung diese russische Okkupation?
Von wo kommen Sie?
Von Hranice.
Haben sie unterwegs etwas erlebt?
Naja ich bin in der Früh aufgewacht und auf einmal schaue ich, ich habe in einer Militärwohnung gewohnt.
Auf einmal höre ich einen Wirbel und denke mir was denn los ist.
Auf einmal kommt die Frau bei der ich geschlafen habe weinend und sagt, dass die Russen einmarschiert sind.
Dann habe ich gefragt was los ist und Sie sagt, dass die ganzen Kasernen besetzt werden.
Man hat gesehen, dass die ganzen Panzer hineingefahren sind.
In die Kaserne selbst?
Nein, nicht in die Kaserne, Außen haben sie sie eingezingelt und die Kanonenrohre richtung Kaserne gehalten.
Wie haben sich die Tschechischen Soldaten verhalten?
Die sind im Alarmzustand, die sind in der Kaserne und bei den Zäunen
und schauen hinaus was denn los ist.
Kaufen die Leute Lebensmittel und Benzin?
Aber angestellt, soviele Leute habe ich noch nie angestellt gesehen bei Lebensmitteln und Benzin.
Die Grenzkontrolle selbst?
Die Grenzkontrolle ist einwandfrei verlaufen, da hatten wir keine Schwierigkeiten.
Haben Sie in den Gesprächen mit den Russen festgestellt, die meisten, so scheint es mir
wenn ich sie aus der Nähe betrachte, sind
sehr junge Burschen.
Ja 17, 18 Jahre.
Es scheinen sehr viele Bauernjungs dabei zu sein.
Ja.
Haben Sie den gleichen Eindruck?
Ja und die Leute sagen sogar, dass sie nicht lesen können.
Ich glaube man sollte ein bischen vorsichtig sein...
Achtung weg die Russen kommen!
Bitte glauben sie nicht, dass unsere Unterbrechungen einfach ein Kasperltheater sind,
aber wir wollen keine Vorsicht außer Acht lassen, wir wollen niemanden provozieren
und vor allen Dingen unsere Kamera behalten.
Wir sind mit 16 Panzer gefahren, Einer war gerade in der Werkstätte,
was er hatte weiß ich nicht mehr,
und er ist uns in den Einsatzraum, in den Verfügungsraum, nachgeführt worden mit dem Tieflader
und wir sind eben in den Verfügungsraum Allentsteig in den Gerotter Wald gefahren.
Wir sind mit dem Bataillonskommando und der zweiten Kompanie Panzergrenadierbataillon 9,
die damals in Weitra gewesen ist, im Raum Pötzles wo das Kommando war,
und sind in den Gerotter Wald hineingefahren und haben uns dort ungemütlich niedergelassen.
In Bad Radkersburg angekommen wurden wir umfassend über die Vorkommnisse in der Tschechoslowakei informiert
und über die Möglichkeit, dass es auch im steirischen Grenzraum
zu Aktionen im Zusammenhang mit einem möglichen Einmarsch in oder gegen Jugoslawien kommen könnte.
Dazu wurde befohlen, dass unsere Kaserne, auch die Kasernen in Straß,
in Ferin und in Feldbach zur Rundumverteidigung einzurichten sei.
Das haben wir getan und haben aus der Kaserne eine kleine Festung gemacht.
Dieser Zustand dauerte bis ungefähr 10. oder 15. September
und danach hatten wir Südbereitschaft, jeden Mittwoch auf Donnerstag und jeden Samstag und Sonntag.
Ab Oktober wechselten wir Verbände uns gegenseitig ab.
Einmal der Schwesterbataillon, einmal wir.
Aber wir sind noch ungefähr 6-7 mal über das Wochenende in Bereitschaft gesessen,
während dieser gesamten Zeit war immer scharfe Munition auf den LKWs verfügbar.
Die Verschläge wurden nicht geöffnet, also es wurde keine Munition an die Männer ausgegeben
aber wir waren immer Marschbereit für einen möglichen Einsatz.
Garnisonen nördlich der Donau wurden durch das Panzerbataillon 10 aus Spratzern...
Das waren 2 Panzerkompanien, M60A1 war damals der modernste Panzer.
Die sind alle im Landmarsch gefahren, nicht mit der Eisenbahn wie man das heute macht.
Die sind dann erst in der Nacht gekommen, die eine ist in die Kaserne Horn gefahren
und die Zweite ist durch die Stadt Horn, damals gab es noch keine Umfahrung, in der Nacht durchgefahren.
Nachdem es ein warmer Tag war waren die Fenster der Leute offen
und auch die meiner spätere Frau, die dort gewohnt hat.
Die Leute sind in Angst und Schrecken, durch die ganz intensiven Panzergeräusche...
Den Leuten ist Angst und Schrecken gekommen weil sie dachten, dass die Russen da sind.
Das kann man sich heute nicht vorstellen.
Wir befinden uns im ehemaligen Dorf Wurmbach, welches sich hier seit dem 12. Jahrhundert befand
und 1939 im Zuge der Einrichtung des Truppenübugnsplatzes Döllersheim, heute Allentsteig, aufgelassen wurde.
Das Dorf wurde allerdings nach 1945 wiederbesiedelt bis in die 1960er Jahre hinein,
sodass es eines der wenigen Dörfer hier auf dem Truppenübungsplatz, dass auch um 1968 noch weitestgehend bestanden hat.
Heute existiert von dem Dorf nur noch die Dorfkapelle, die gepfelgt wird,
alle anderen Bauten sind teilweise abgetragen worden, teilweise einfach über die Jahrzente hinweg verfallen.
Es gibt die sogenannte Lighter Scan Technik, wo von Flugzeugen aus mit einem Laserscanner
die Oberfläche abgetastet wird und mit einem relativ komplizierten mathematischen Verfahren
der Wald und die Vegetation weggerechnet werden kann.
Übrig bleibt eine relativ hohe Auflösung der Oberfläche, mit der es möglich ist die Grundrisse
der Fundamentmauern, die heute im Wald versteckt sind, erkennen zu können.
Auf dieser Basis ist es möglich, den Bauzustand zumindest des frühen 20. Jahrhunderts rekonstruieren zu können.
Wir befinden uns ganz am Westrand des Truppenübungsplatzes Allentsteig, im Bereich der ehemaligen Ortschaft Pötzles.
Dort drüben ist das berühmte Stift Zwettl.
Hier ist ein Biwak gestanden mit drei Häusern.
Hier in diesem Bereich und im Waldstück davor war das Panzerbataillon 10 untergebracht,
hier die Panzergrenadierkompanier, drüben war die Panzerkompanie mit den M60.
Die Biwaks wurden inzwischen abgerissen, das hier ist jetzt ein Parkplatz für
übende Truppen, es ist auch eine große Panzerschießbahn daneben und es ist hier diese Kapelle.
Diese Kapelle ist Renoviert worden, viele Kapellen hier am Truppenübungsplatz wurden
wieder soweit restauriert, dass sie auch zur Not benutzt werden können,
auch hier finden von Zeit zu Zeit heilige Messen statt.
Das war die Rote Linie, welche in Richtung Norden nicht überschritten werden durfte.
Und das hier war die Rote Linie.
Anfang September 1968 wurden die anfänglich 21 Sowjetischen Divisionen auf 8
und schließlich auf 5 reduziert und in die zentrale Gruppe der Truppen zusammengefasst.
Infolgedessen wurde das erste Panzerbataillon nach Salzburg Siezenheim zurückverlegt.
Am 14. September 1968 machte sich die Panzerfliegerabwehr Batterie 3 ebenfalls auf den Rückmarsch von
Allentsteig nach Krems und die Garnison Mautern.
Die mobile Radarstellung der ersten Fliegermelde Radarkompanie verblieb bis zum 25. September
bei Hellmonsödt und kehrte schließlich nach Salzburg zurück.
Ende September war somit der friedensmäßige Normalzustand wiederhergestellt.
Die Krise um die Tschechoslowakei war damit im Umfeld der Republik Österreich beendet.
Für nachfolgende Generationen stellt sich
jedoch die Frage, ob eine derartige Situation
wie 1968 sich in einem Staatenbund wie der Europäischen Union wiederholen könnte.
Niemand kann heute sagen was morgen sein wird.
Das lehrt uns die Geschichte.
Niemand hat den Zusammenbruch des Kommunismus real vorhergesehen, niemand den Arabischen Frühling.
So wurden auch viele andere Einsätze die von heute auf morgen entstanden nicht vorgesehen
und man kann auch heute, also 2018, nicht sagen was morgen konkret sein wird.
Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen, wir haben heutzutage ganz andere Bedrohungen,
Migration, Cyberbedrohungen, usw.
Aber momentan kann ich mir das in Europa nicht vorstellen.